It's a great thing to know with people
like in your relationships here,
here's the key to a good relationship.
It's not the only one,
but watch your person carefully,
carefully,
and whenever they do something that you
would like them to do more of,
tell them that that was really good and
mean it and it's not manipulative
because if it's manipulative it won't
work.
It's like you have to say,
wow,
I'm so glad you did that.
Did you have to be precise?
Here's what you just did that I thought
was great and Oh boy,
that's so nice that you've noticed.
I can't believe they could notice.
It's like,
you know,
you do that 20 times and the person will
be like the rat.
That's just pushing the lever for
cocaine.
You know,
so,
but no,
I'm serious.
It's skinner established this bf skinner
noticed this a long time ago.
Reward is intensely useful in terms of
modifying behavior,
but the problem is is that it's really
hard to notice when things are going
right,
right?
Because you're kind of prime to notice
when things are going wrong and so you
use threat and punishment more often as
agents of of shaping the people that
you're around.
Because you know when everything's going
right,
it's like,
what are you going to say?
Everything's going right.
It turns to zero.
You just assume it and that's not good.
That's not good.
You want to pay attention and if the.
If you're a person,
your children,
your wife,
your whoever,
your mother,
your sister,
if you want them to,
if you want to rectify your
relationships with them,
and I'm not saying to do this in a
manipulative wait,
won't work,
but if they do something that's
promoting harmony and peace and
goodwill,
it's like attend to it.
Tell them that you noticed.
It's like it's so useful and you have to
get rid of your grudges and your
resentment to do that,
right?
Because you don't want you to kind of
mad at your sister and then you know she
does something good.
You think there is no god damn way,
I'm going to reward you for that.
So you ignore her when she does
something good.
It's like,
that's brilliant.
That is because then you've just
punished her for doing what you want.
And people do that with their kids all
the time,
you know,
because they let the kids dominate them.
Then they get resentful.
Then the kid will run up to them to show
them something that's kind of
spectacular and they'll,
they're not happy.
They'll say,
oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm working.
You know,
little kid has all sad about that and
he's just learned something so.
And it's not perhaps what you want them
to learn.
And so you have to keep your,
your relationship with your children
pristine.
And that means that you can't hold a
grudge or resent them.
And that means that you have to help
them learn how to behave so that you
liked them.
And that way if they,
if you like them and you're kind of
sensible and maybe your partner also
likes them.
So you know,
you got a consensus going there,
there's a reasonable possibility that
other people will actually liked them
too,
including other children.
And then the world will open up to them,
you know,
then you'll bring them to people's
houses and the people will actually
smile at them and them a pat on the head
and instead of thinking,
oh my God,
that Brad's coming to visit again,
I wonder what it will break this time,
you know?
And that's just a horrible thing for
your child to experience repetitively in
situation after situation.
All they learned is that adults have a
false smile,
but they're really lying all the time.
God,
it's like a bit of hell.
And there's a lot of children who are
trapped in that.
It's really awful to see.
I can see kids like that when I walked
down the street,
you know,
it's like their little doomed things and
there they are and you know,
they're screwed in 15 different ways and
there's no way out of it.
It's really awful.
So I would not recommend that you do
that.
It's better to notice that you're a bit
of a monster or a lot of a monster.
And notice that you are much happier
with the people around you when they
behave in accordance with reasonable
social social norms,
and then you actually feel genuinely
connected to them and you want to work
on their behalf so that everything works
out.
But if you think you're a good person
and that you'd never do anything that
was harmful to your children,
then you can just forget about that
because you'll never take it seriously
enough to actually learn.